At this altitude,
I can run flat out for a half mile before my hands start shaking.
You put some questions.
I'm a cybernetic organism,
living tissue.
This episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for years.
I love audiobooks and I've two to recommend right off the bat.
Number one is press my favorite audio book of all time,
and that is the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
The only audiobook I've wanted to immediately listen to a second time.
As soon as I finished,
it's amazing.
You will thank me.
The graveyard book.
The second is vagabonding by Rolf Potts,
which had a huge impact on my life and formed the basis for a lot of what became
the four hour workweek.
So all you need to do to get your free 30 day trial is go to audible.com forward
slash 10 and you can choose one of those two books,
the graveyard book vagabonding or more than 180,000 audio programs.
So that could be a book.
That could be a magazine,
that could be a newspaper,
could be a class.
It's that easy.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim,
that's audible.com forward slash Tim and grab a book.
Enjoy.
This episode is brought to you by 99 designs when your business needs a logo,
website,
business card,
thumbnail,
or any other design.
I recommend checking out 99 designs.
I use them myself.
I've used them for many years.
I used them to create book cover prototypes for the four hour body,
which went on to becoming number one New York Times bestseller.
I've also used them for banner ads,
illustrations,
and much more.
With 99 designs.
You get a variety of original designs from designers around the world.
Give your feedback and then pick your favorite.
Your happiness is guaranteed.
So check out some of my competitions in designs and some of your competitions
and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss.
Show listeners@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim and right now you can get
a free $99 upgrade on your first design,
so check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash Tim
fusses lows.
Good and dog.
This is Tim Ferriss and welcome to another episode of the Tim Ferriss Show where
it is my job to deconstruct world class performers,
whether they are from the worlds of entertainment,
chess,
sports or otherwise.
This episode is a special double header if features one interview and one
performance,
which is a new thing.
First up is cascade,
You can say hello to him at cascade on most of social,
he is widely considered one of the founding fathers of Progressive House music.
He's been voted America's Best Dj twice by DJ Times,
headline,
Coachella four times and has been nominated for Grammy's five times.
Next up you'll hear Sekou Andrews,
that's s,
e,
k,
O,
U.
Andrew's,
so at Sekou Andrews across social,
and he is the most impressive poetic voice I've ever heard.
I first saw him perform a ted where he blew my mind and so I approached him
afterwards.
He is a schoolteacher,
turned two time national poetry slam champion.
He's presented privately for Barack Obama,
Bano,
Oprah Winfrey.
The list goes on and on.
Each one of these takes a few minutes to get warmed up,
so be patient.
I know it's not a specialty for those in the digital world,
but there are gems in both of them.
Among other things,
cascade covers his first breaks,
making his own luck,
formative music influences if his music were,
or I should say rather electronic or dance music,
we're a wine tasting.
What would you recommend the varietals be?
Who should be listened to?
What were his biggest albums in the early days?
And we dig into his note taking process.
As you may know,
I'm a nerd,
that kind of thing.
I want to know the origins of his biggest hits.
How did they come to be?
What was the time span between the first note taking and then going live,
et cetera.
We talk about all of that.
Sacred will inspire you to be inspired by your story,
so if you want to change your narrative,
your internal dialogue to be more successful,
this is a good talk to listen to.
If you want to get back on the horse or have an effective pep talk in your back
pocket,
this might be the recording you listened to over and over again.
Now you should be patient.
I'm going to mention this again because there's a lot of practical philosophy
embedded in,
in between the lines.
So you have to listen to it all and you have to listen carefully.
And uh,
these are very contrasting a,
I should say,
different rather,
uh,
personalities and very different performances.
And so I hope that you enjoy both of them.
You can certainly skip around and I'll mention just a couple of notes.
These were both recorded at a live event in Los Angeles and that sold out in 30
minutes based on an email that I sent out to my newsletter subscribers.
If you're not on the newsletter,
it's free and you get a lots of exclusives and cool stuff like five bullet
Friday,
which has more than a 60% open rate across the board for people to know what
that is,
that's unheard of.
Uh,
and you can sign up,
try it out for a week or2@fourhourworkweek.com forward slash Friday.
So all spelled out for our work week.com forward slash Friday.
Now,
since it was a live event,
there were a couple of audio glitches early on.
And in the case of cascade we had a mic failure and I ended up pulling out my
lovelier Mike,
you know the clip on mic that was threaded down my shirt,
pulling it out and handing that back and forth for a bit.
So you might hear a couple of missteps here and there,
but what you missed was a little bit of background.
He was raised Mormon,
he was born in Chicago,
he went to Utah for college and where he grew up was where they filmed Ferris
Bueller's day off among the other things.
So without further ado,
please enjoy this episode with cascade and Sekou Andrews.
When did you have your first,
what you would consider your first break or,
uh,
mentor
in Music?
Uh,
let's see.
When I moved to San Francisco,
uh,
I reached out to own records that we're a small boutique label based right in
the city there,
south of market area.
And um,
really they were the only people I knew in San Francisco Cause I had some demos
and I was mailing music to people and that wasn't going so well but they'd
showed a little interest and I moved there.
Luckily they hired me for like,
the funny thing is is like my wife and I,
we couldn't even make rent for what we were.
I mean she supported me for many years.
She was working for Levi Strauss at the headquarters there and it was great and
I was like,
yeah,
you get a good job.
I'm going to do music.
We'll see how that turns out.
I'm awesome.
Who are you married?
Well you know,
if that were a stock that she had bought,
she was pretty happy.
I'm done.
I'm imagining,
I mean it's worked out.
The when did you realize that this is something you could do to support yourself
full time
or even think that was possible?
It's like the mid two thousands,
so 10 years ago,
you know,
10,
11 years ago.
Um,
but people that are like,
when did you really decide you were going to do music?
And I was one of those people that never wanted to admit that that would,
I was,
that's what I was doing.
I kept telling me,
she's like,
well what are you doing?
What are you,
what's your plan?
And she was pretty organized and very driven.
And um,
I think I didn't want to like say that because I didn't want to be a failure.
I didn't want to have like,
no,
I'm going to be a musician,
I'm going to write music,
I want to,
my whole thing was there.
It was like,
no,
it's a cool hobby.
I'm doing it.
These guys hired me.
I'll go there,
I'll work for low,
we'll see what happens.
Let's just,
we'll see.
We'll see what happens.
That was always my thing.
So what did you at the time when people would ask you,
cause I know people do this in San Francisco as well as many other cities,
but like so,
so what do you do?
How would you answer that at the time
music,
which is San Francisco,
people think that's cool.
There's enough art community there and people are like,
oh,
that's cool.
What do you,
you know,
how you living?
Like I'm my wife.
She just got a good shop.
Uh,
so is it,
uh,
I had in the,
in the course of doing research for this,
read that when you,
when you went from Chicago to Utah,
just to,
I know we're jumping around chronologically that that is when you started sort
of producing or creating your own music because there wasn't much of a scene if
it does that accurate.
This is a great,
this is a great point.
So what happened is this,
I'm like,
oh,
okay.
I got into University of Utah,
um,
for Mormons out there now more than is out there.
It's like for me,
I grew up as a kid in Chicago.
There wasn't very many Mormon cause I thought I'll go to school and knew Tom
Mito the Mormon people,
see what they about,
you know,
I was friends with all these Jewish kids growing in Chicago.
It was like all my friends are Jewish,
you know,
like anyway,
so I went to Utah and um,
that was great.
But I growing up going nightclubs all through high school,
teen clubs were a big deal in Chicago and that's how I got introduced into
house.
Music was very much a part of my life.
I was collecting records,
you know,
as a hobby.
I was a DJ.
Um,
so when I got there I'm like,
what is it?
What is this music?
You guys are releasing it.
This is terrible.
You know,
like I've got crates of records.
When are you coming to my house?
I got some speakers.
So I started throwing my own parties and I really had to get involved.
That was definitely a point where I was like,
wow,
if I'm going to be a part of this scene or,
or make music,
I'm going to have to be active instead of just like some passive guy.
Cause in Chicago,
I used to be the guy that went out and collected records in occasionally played
at a friend's house party.
But when I got to Utah,
I was like,
if I want to do this and we'd have to make my own thing,
which is good because it inspired me to get involved in and really get
motivated.
How
loud enough now?
Uh,
how did you get your first gear or equipment?
Of course,
that's evolved a lot since,
but uh,
so I hit a local club owner up in Utah and I was like,
I got crates of records.
Um,
and what's your worst night that you have?
What's the slowest night?
When he was like,
Monday,
I'm not even open.
I'm like,
dude,
let me come down on Monday night.
And this is a bar that had opened in the forties and it had all its original
decor.
It's called club Manhattan is amazing place in the basement.
Anyway,
the owners like,
you know,
I'll give you a cut of the door.
You have your friends come in,
whatever,
invite some people and we'll see what happens.
Anyway,
that turned out the night was a smash.
I mean I did it for five years and I ended up doing two nights a week.
It was Monday.
And then when I took on a Thursday and things worked almost instantly,
uh,
and I quit my,
you know,
I was working at a clothing store,
trying to support myself,
going to school and a,
I quit.
Like after the first week I was like,
Oh,
I'm done with that.
I'm just going to do this DJ thing.
This is great and I can make some cash and I can pay for school.
Um,
so it started clicking and then when I was making enough money,
I started buying my first studio equipment and I slowly started producing songs
and getting into that and learning my way around the studio and like,
wow,
how does this sampler work?
How does a digital audio workstation,
how does this all work?
Um,
and just understanding that,
which was great cause it was like I was going to school,
I thought it was really busy at the time,
but I realize now that like I had a lot of free time.
I'm so busy,
I'm going to see her for 10 hours and work on this song,
you know,
like,
um,
anyway,
so I had a lot of times it kind of just learn my craft.
Um,
so it was a good time for me.
and then when I moved to San Francisco,
that definitely took it up a notch.
I worked from records for a couple of years and it was good cause I was,
I knew how to make the music,
but I didn't understand anything about the business.
I wasn't really interested in business.
I was like,
I just want to make music.
I don't know all this other stuff.
Um,
but it forced me to learn some things about the business,
which was cool because I could see like,
oh,
you can't just like hang out in your room and make tracks.
You've got to get out and promote them and be a part of the scene and get out
there and people want to know who you are as an artist who's writing these
songs.
Um,
and yeah,
so it kind of slowly started building up from there in San Francisco
and I'm sure you get approached a lot with people who are hoping to create their
own electronic music or maybe they already are.
If,
if one of those people were to ask you how to create sort of a self directed
Mba,
they're like,
look,
I,
I have the time,
I have a little bit of resources.
What skills should I learn?
Like what's the,
what does the curriculum look like in terms of setting the stage for being a
successful
musician in that category?
On this John Ra,
I always tell people that are getting started out.
I mean now there are schools for this and you can go,
you know,
18 month things to 12 month program.
So it's a lot easier to learn the craft now than it was back then.
Um,
back then I was buying like these $25 magazines from the UK electronic musician.
I'm like,
what in the hell $25.
Like I'm broke man.
But anyway,
they had a lot of good tutorials so it was very different back then.
Now it's a little more accessible.
Um,
but I always tell people,
I mean like what's your passion?
What do you truly love about this music is do you want to write?
Do you want to produce,
are you a songwriter?
Find out what you do best and put all your time and energy into that.
Like,
are you really good at just deejaying?
Is that what you do?
You're a selector.
You can pull get tracks,
you have a good ear because there's some people that do that and do that really
well.
Then go out and figure out how to maximize that.
Figuring out what it is that you do best and really run with it.
Like maybe you and you gotta be honest with yourself.
It's like one of those things that it might take a year or two to discover.
You're out in the mix,
you're going to clubs or you're trying to get gigs or whatever it is.
But I think it's just kind of good to sit back and like check the climate and
like,
what am I doing well in order people drawn to me like what's working here?
And then just do that as much as you can.
How did you,
and feel free to
two
verify this also again just in the course of doing research,
but when did you realize that you are very good at more melodic ah,
music as opposed to eat or rhythmic based?
And I would love you for even to just differentiate those for people.
Uh,
well much of dance music is very rhythmic.
My Dad was like,
why is the kick drum so damn loud?
And I'm like best dance music there.
Um,
so it's very many people see this repetitive whatever that that's kind of the
old dance music cause it was pretty simplistic.
We didn't have,
the technology wasn't as sophisticated as now.
Um,
and when I moved to San Francisco in 2000,
that was kind of like the beginnings of more melodic electronic music.
Songwriting was getting involved and there are a couple of acts.
There was one band locally called solstice.
They were great,
extremely talented.
Um,
they're a band,
but it was more electronic sounding.
And I remember sitting at the label,
they were assigned to ohm.
I'm like,
because I had been knowing when all this stuff that was very sample heavy and
rhythmic kind of the trend at the time,
like,
but I wasn't making any head room.
I wasn't,
I was,
there was no headway.
I was just kinda like,
cause I was like every dude out there,
you know,
my demo sounded just like everybody else's.
Anyway,
as I kind of sat in the office and sat back and was like,
thinking what would work and how could I make myself different?
Um,
I thought,
you know,
there's not that much melodic stuff out there.
What if I focused more on the song?
And I had been in the scene quite a long time,
even at that point in my career that I'd seen like this goes in cycles and
people get into different styles and um,
one production style,
progressive houses.
Cool.
Today.
Techno's cool.
Tomorrow,
drum and bass is cool.
Next week it moves really quick in the underground.
Um,
so I was like,
man,
if I focused more on songs and song writing,
that could be my thing.
That could be my space and there's not very many people doing it.
So I could make my own name that way.
And it would be more evergreen,
I guess,
in that respect.
Right.
More durability.
Yeah.
And then,
I mean,
that was just,
I didn't think of that at the time,
but that's kind of what happened.
Um,
naturally.
And it all kind of coincided with me meeting some people that were really good
songwriters that were like,
man,
you're talented in the studio.
But dude,
that's just one part of it.
Making the music a song.
That's an instrumental,
that's half a song has half an idea.
And I was like,
what man?
Oh my gosh,
this is great.
I thought that was a song.
That's a song,
you know?
And they're like,
no,
this is,
it's not.
So I met and hung out with some people that had some different ideas.
Um,
are there any particular songwriters who had a large influence on your,
that you look up to?
Um,
I mean I'd go with like classics like staying or the Morrissey,
you know,
I grew up in the eighties,
so like new way was a big deal for me.
Um,
Robert Smith,
the cure.
I love this guy's and brilliant songwriter.
Um,
so that's stuff I was always drawn to.
But uh,
you know,
as I work with more songwriters like okay,
can develop,
this is a craft.
I fancy myself a bit of a writer.
Writing songs is different,
but it's still kind of just getting your idea on a little short three minute
piece.
So kind of marrying the two things that I was doing,
but then that,
that's when everything kind of changed in my career.
Things really as I started producing that kind of music,
people notice me and I started touring quickly after that.
I mean 2003 is really when things started to move.
I think that year I did like 70 or 80 shows and I was like,
this is insane.
And that's when my wife's like,
what did I sign up for?
What?
You're never here,
you know,
what,
what is your record for consecutive shows or consecutive days with shows?
Um,
I dunno,
I've never counted that.
That's really,
that's a really good question.
I know I've done like 12 or 14.
I mean,
it's not uncommon for me to do 23,
24,
25 shows in a month.
Um,
um,
in the summer.
The summer is extremely busy.
Um,
I mean it's always somewhere,
somewhere,
so it's busy all the time.
But I always take our winter.
I always kind of slow down a little bit.
How do you,
what,
uh,
what type of rituals or self care do you have two,
keep from getting extremely sick,
uh,
during that type of just onslaught and a month where you're constantly
performing?
Is there any particular diet?
It's stick shift performance?
Part of it's not hard for me because,
uh,
I feel very natural.
I mean,
I've been doing this for over 20 years,
so for me,
I feel very at home on stage and doing in my space and I feel like at that just
naturally keeps things out.
It's a very,
uh,
Obrovac,
you know,
it's like a workout really.
I walk upstage of lost five pounds.
I'm trying to just in sweat.
Um,
so I think that part of it is actually quite healthy.
And then just like eating and living clean,
really,
why I'm on the road.
Um,
you know,
we're traveling from place to place.
It's like we traveled during the day and we sleep,
we sleep on the planes and we perform at night.
Um,
and when I say we,
I traveled with a small clique of guys that,
uh,
that helped me execute the shows.
Um,
although then the artists have a tour manager or photographer,
videographer,
a lighting guy of visual guy.
Sometimes the sound guy,
it depends on the size of the show,
but it can be anywhere from five people up to 25 people.
Um,
but I think that kind of philosophy is just kind of worked its way down to,
to everybody.
I work with,
um,
that and when I can,
I travel with my family.
I'm married and I have three children,
so I'm always trying to figure out,
okay,
how can I make this work?
Um,
you know,
putting the stones in the,
in the bucket like okay,
what's truly important here and how can I,
how can I fill the bucket with the things that are really important to me.
How would you describe your parenting style?
I'm sorry,
I'm your parenting style.
How would you describe your parent or how do you think of parenting?
My style of parenting.
Wow.
You're definitely never been asked that.
Um,
Oh man,
I wish Naomi was here.
My,
my wife,
she's,
she's uh,
she's amazing cause listen,
she gambled on me and took a,
she had no idea where this was heading or where it was going.
Um,
and she's really been there to take care of the family and been like my biggest
fan and champion in my corner from day one.
And without your,
honestly none of it would be possible.
Um,
because it is fully a team effort on every front in my business.
She my business manager for 10 years.
Um,
and she's been the primary parent and the disciplinary and in our home because
she's there and she has to be,
um,
cause I'm not there as often as she is.
So,
um,
that's extremely important to note that cause uh,
that's how it's worked in my home.
Um,
me,
I'm kind of,
she always gets mad when I'm angry at the kid.
She's like,
no,
no.
I have to be the ingrown.
You have to be like the soft guy that gives them everything.
I'm totally cool.
I can do that.
And like ice cream,
it's Monday.
No,
it's usually Monday and Tuesday are typically my weekend cause I come home on
Sunday or Monday from traveling all weekend.
And then I've got Monday and Tuesday a window to kind of hang out with the
family.
Um,
you know when they're back at school.
So I'm always wanting to do like,
let's go to a movie on Monday night.
Yeah,
no.
Uh,
I am,
I have a constant note taker and I watched an interview of yours where you
talked about writing down ideas for songs in a notebook.
Do you still take a lot?
A lot of notes.
I have a notebook just like that at home filled with chipper [inaudible]
highlights and little things.
Um,
yes.
I think the interview was about early on in my career.
I got pulled over,
stopped in London after I'd been on like a four show binge.
Sure.
I showed up at the border and I looked,
probably completely cracked out.
I hadn't slept in days and uh,
they pulled me over because I didn't have the right permits or the right work
credentials to get in there.
And I sat in this room for 12 hours and I hadn't eaten.
I don't know,
it was a very down moment for me,
but they had taken apart this notebook and photocopied everything.
I mean,
I,
you know,
this thing was almost full when I got there.
Um,
but I keep one of these with me and I thought they thought it was some like drug
log,
the of where I was traveling,
my drop.
So they had photocopied everything and like,
what does this mean?
I'm like that it says that do my laundry when I get home,
what he's talking about.
It's not code.
I need to do my laundry.
There's no code there,
man.
Um,
eventually they let me off and everything turned out okay.
Except I was escorted back on the plane the next day with a cop all the way to
the them.
That was funny.
Um,
another time.
Uh,
but yeah,
I mean this is how I organize my life.
Uh,
I have a lot of ideas and thoughts all the time and I just continued to write
things down and look over that and you know,
perfect.
That process,
you have a particular routine for reviewing the notes or is it more of a
journaling exercise?
We just put it down and you don't go back and review it.
Um,
for me it's in the morning,
kind of when I first sit down,
I look at what I was trying to accomplish,
uh,
the day before and what's kind of overlapping and what didn't happen and kind of
carries over into that next day.
And then I looked throughout the week.
Um,
and then I look at any potential song ideas or any notes that I have or ideas
that could lead to his song.
Um,
what do those look like?
I mean,
I'm assuming,
do your laundry isn't,
isn't one of them,
but like what,
what is,
what form does it take?
Is it just a,
could it be a single word?
Could it be,
um,
I phrase I always like to use the example,
I wrote a song called 4:00 AM and it's one of my more popular ones and my
catalog.
Thank you.
Um,
and I'll tell this story cause it's,
I was playing it kinking not too far down the street.
Um,
I was in from San Francisco and uh,
when I played kinking there was like a 6:40 AM flight.
So I'd play all night and then I could get French toast across the street and I
take my luggage,
eat the French toast,
and then get in the cab and catch the flight,
get home,
get home on Sunday morning to see my family.
Anyway,
um,
I was sitting there at 4:00 AM and I,
it was just one of those massive nights in my career where I kinda hit a moment
where I was like,
this is really gonna work.
I have a few of these moments,
uh,
along my career.
But that was one of them where I was like,
what an incredible night.
And I mean,
looking back,
it was a very small club and it holds like four or 500 people maybe.
Um,
but it was like line around the block and I just knew things were clicking.
So I was on this,
I was on a high,
I was just floating and it was four in the morning when I walked into the French
toast place.
And I got my luggage there and I opened up my bag and I'm like,
I have to write a song about 4:00 AM and sleepless gliding.
And these words started coming to me and it was just like a couple of phrases
and talking about for eem meeting French toast and gliding on the streets
without any sleep.
And that became the first first.
Um,
and then it just blossomed into an idea.
I think it's kind of like looking back at my notes when I'm in the studio and
thinking like,
is this,
is this something that anyone could else could relate to?
Um,
you know,
and then making a song out of it really.
How long did it take from that initial note taking to being out in the world as
a song?
Right.
I think I wrote that album was about six months later,
so it was sitting around circled in that book,
you know,
I'd go back to it and like,
oh,
that's a cool idea.
Um,
and then when I was in there,
I was like,
I should develop this more and sit down and write a song about that moment.
Do you collect anything or,
I had records,
records,
vinyl,
lots and lots of vinyl.
Thousands and thousands of records.
Okay.
Any particular genre?
A,
it's all,
I mean it's mostly particularly,
it's like dance music,
house music,
early house music stuff that I started when I collecting when I was a kid.
Um,
then when I had a little bit more money I started buying like old new wave
records,
old punk records,
uh,
some hip hop,
you know,
just stuff that interested me.
Bands that were seminal to me personally.
So for dance music,
if people here,
like myself,
I'm,
I'm naive of the entire genre and it really,
I can enjoy it,
answers it better.
The first thing about it,
if I wanted to do the equivalent of a wine tasting with dance music and he's
like,
try like,
oh yeah,
like I think that's where low,
I'm not sure and try a few different options to educate myself.
Were there any particular artists or albums that you would suggest people start
with?
Um,
among many,
of course.
I'm not asking you to pick favorites.
I guess I am.
That's kind of an old school way of thinking.
I think if you're into electronic music now,
I'd flip open Spotify and go listen to,
there's like a million playlists that I run cascade radio and I add four or five
tracks on there every,
every week that I'm like,
oh,
this is stuff that I'm feeling.
And it's predominantly electronic music.
I wouldn't say dance music cause there's a lot of left field stuff in there.
Um,
but yeah,
seminal records,
I mean daft punk homework to me is still kind of like one of the top records set
defined our John Rhe so,
um,
or discovery,
not as big a fan as discovery.
That's a very controversial thing to say.
But I'm a homework guy cause I dunno,
that hit me at the right time,
time in my life.
Um,
that's a big one.
Uh,
any craft work record?
Um,
I don't know.
There's a lot of stuff out there,
but I think,
I think going to Spotify and hitting it because
what's interesting about electronic music,
I think one at one point it was a genre and it was a very specific kind of
surrounded a culture.
But now really and truly this is pretty much how most of the music's made.
I mean,
everybody works on a computer,
on a laptop,
even if the recording rock and roll,
and it's all augmented and processed and it's all electronic driven.
Um,
for better or for worse,
I mean that's another conversation.
I could argue both sides.
Um,
I see the downsides in that,
but really the way we're thinking 25,
30 years ago working with Troy machines and sampling and oh,
recording on a multitrack that's in a computer.
This is just how everyone operates today.
I mean,
that's what pop music is.
he listened to it on the radio.
To me,
it's all dance music.
I'm like,
ah,
we were doing that 10 years ago.
This is cool.
There's a modern take on what was happening a long time ago.
So I know,
uh,
you've,
we have,
we have a hard out and I'm really happy that you're able to make it.
We have a couple of minutes.
Uh,
so I'm going to ask a couple of the normal questions that I tend do when
wrapping up.
What book or books have you gifted most to other people,
if any?
Um,
I knew you were going to ask this.
I thought about it and I'm like,
man,
I don't give any books away.
Um,
but I did just recently give lights out to a friend,
so I'm going to say that cause it's the most recent thing I read,
um,
lights out.
Yeah.
And it's about a cyber terrorism and how they were going to cut the power off
and we're going to be screwed.
Um,
it was a really interesting read and it scared the crap out of me as,
uh,
if you had to pick an underappreciated festival,
what would you pick?
Oh,
that's a great question.
And I'm stalling to,
Oh man,
there's so many cool.
They,
if I wasn't here in California,
a quick cello cause to me that's still is the best festival in the entire world.
And I've played literally hundreds if not thousands of festivals,
but,
um,
I dunno,
they got a lot of cool stuff going on in New York electric soon.
New York's actually really cool.
It's on Randall's island and you're looking at the skyline while you're playing
is pretty cool.
Um,
but there's a handful of those,
man,
that's the one I'd have to think thing like go through my diet would go through
my diary and be like,
where have I been recently?
You do around two sometime.
Uh,
when you think of the word successful,
who's the first person who comes to mind and why?
My wife and she's,
uh,
she's the Rock and she's who I look to all the time.
It seems like she kind of effort is simply effortlessly glides between family
life and,
um,
supporting me and making everything work.
Uh,
so yeah,
she's,
she's success.
She's the model of success to me.
If you had one billboard
anywhere,
you can put anything on it,
what would you put on it?
Let's see.
Probably The Times Square just because that's where most people would see it.
I Dunno.
I'd probably throw it in my brands up there,
Redo or something or cascade.
I don't know.
On a big picture of me like I'm coming to get you.
Do you have any,
any mottos or quotes or anything that you stayed to yourself when you're getting
ready to perform that you could put on the
billboard?
MMM.
Now,
but one of the quotes that always comes back to me and my career and something I
always think back to every time I left the house,
my dad would always say,
remember who you are?
And I'm always like,
man,
that's now that I'm a father.
This is a very profound thing to me.
At the time I was like,
man,
dad,
you're so weird.
Like when I forget who I am,
let me see now I'm like,
Gosh,
that guy's going to see a smart,
you know,
that basically answers the next one
question.
So I think we'll,
we'll wrap up with just asking you where people can find more about you,
your work,
your music,
whether it's a anywhere online,
early.
Yeah,
I dunno,
I'm on Twitter,
Instagram,
all the social networks.
Cascade music.com come and check me out.
I appreciate the time you got to cascade with,
with two K at cascade.
Kska d yeah.
Yeah.
If you follow me on Instagram,
you get some pretty crazy photos on there,
so sure we would thank you so much.
I really appreciate the time.
[inaudible]
anybody have taken a soul self and anybody,
I know you gotta take selfies,
but have you taken a sole selfie?
Y'All don't know nothing about this.
I'm a hip young.
Put y'all on what?
Put you all on the sole selfie is the way it is.
You can remind yourself instantly that's you are mighty enough that you are
beautiful enough,
that you are powerful enough and strong enough to get through anything.
And I want you all to do what we right now,
everybody's standing up real quick name.
I'm thinking,
I stand up.
Stand up,
stand up.
All you gotta do.
I ain't got to do well.
My hand in the air.
Turn it around.
Make a little claw like you holding a hand mirror,
fended off your charm,
lean into it.
And when you see how powerful and beauty and mighty you are,
you got to say the words I,
Oh,
let's say we me ready?
One,
two,
three.
I am,
oh,
hold on,
hold on.
I won't believe you hit it again.
I am
Oh
damn rights.
You Austin and all your power.
Sit down in your power damn rights.
You will.
That's how you get through those days,
right?
One of those days like I'm having right now.
You know when my drive crashes,
right?
When my self worth stalls by the side of the road,
my ambitions check engine light comes on mid Hustle and I find myself at my
bathroom mirror,
finger to glass,
scratching the word can't into the hardened steam.
But as I stare at my murky reflection,
but these broken down eyes,
my reflection sees its reflection in me from the other side and thinks it's
still,
oh,
I didn't know what he thinks he sees but must not be looking at me because I am
so don't be wasting my tears.
I am more than enough to get through this.
I got a scrap book full of,
I can't do it to prove it for I maintain a level of authenticity in everything I
do.
So my awesome mission is not speculation but irrefutable truth.
In fact,
the Census Bureau just released a report that two out of every three people are
awesome.
And if that is true then out of you and you and I question,
we must now ask ourselves this.
Which one of you two was the one that sucks because I am
like finding money,
getting dirty laundry.
Awesome.
Woo.
Like parking next at one meter that's broken.
Awesome.
Like,
like that perfect person at that perfect time.
Seeing that perfect thing.
Awesome.
Like making a living,
doing what you live for.
Like somewhere rocking out in New York City is a dude whose resume actually
reads National Air Guitar Tamping it
somewhere in the Ukraine is a woman who boasts a trophy for national sand art
champion.
Here you in Los Angeles is a dude who has earned the title national poetry slam
champion and,
and thank you.
Thank you.
I appreciate that.
Because to most of the working world,
all three of those titles are equally freaking ridiculous.
But
the most awesome five people on the planet are we who embrace our
ridiculousness.
We live what we love and we love incorrigibly,
which is why I sleep quite well,
but I go to bed horribly.
Anybody else always hopped up on a triple shot of purpose,
juggling my dreams like 13 flaming swords and chasing my aspirations through the
graveyard shift so that the world can awake to my Austem.
Neisha snus look it up and I'll admit I don't limit,
I used to think that awesome was the word for it.
You know,
surfers and Skateboarders,
you know,
smokers and valley girls,
but I was like totally mistaken.
Awesome is gangster awesome is stupid,
fresh awesome.
Has the new comp and the new cool being the new bomb diggity and the new bees
knees.
My new mantra that helps me breathe into all that I believe in,
see that within me is all the Mike [inaudible] need because there are those days
when I'm pushed to the edge was still waters meet earth and I fall to my knees
to look upon the water surface.
But as I stare at my mercury reflection with these broken down eyes,
God sees his reflection in me from the other side and thinks to herself,
oh,
I don't know what he thinks he sees,
but he must not be looking at me because I am
like the science of miracles and the mathematics of purpose.
Awesome.
Like how the mind,
the mind can always calculate the what of who and the when of where.
But the soul must solve for y awesome.
Like the thought of God and logic.
Having faith that we will figure ourselves out.
Awesome.
Like how the moment I truly discovered the great I am is the same moment I
discovered of truly great.
I am and I am not perfect,
but I'm perfect.
Like I am.
I'm not beautiful.
Like I used to be
beautiful like I am like the scar where abreast once was like survival.
Where a death once.
Well it's like the better.
Where a best once was.
Every hair a trophy,
every wrinkle fold a story.
Every pound of fat.
A challenge reminded me that there is always something to pursue
and always something to celebrate.
That is why I never smile for no reason.
That is a concept I don't believe in.
Do join never without a reason to show off your teeth a bit.
Let me see him.
Let me see their baby.
There you go.
Spread out shit.
Seeks a bit.
Let your gums breathe a bit.
If you can learn to reach deep for it.
You can take yourself a piece of bliss and make yourself a feast of it.
Like when you go buy a smoothie
and they fill it to fool,
right and making more than your cup can hold,
but instead of letting it just spill all over what they do,
what they do,
they give you a little extra cough and you feel like you just want a smoothie
lottery of their hair.
Awesome.
Like that perfect day.
What was yours?
That perfect day,
right?
One of mine was like the first time.
Yeah.
Stretch Limo driver pulled up to the first,
the five star hotel to transport me to my first class flight after my sold out
show and curiously peering at me through the rear view mirror.
He asked what do you do for a living
and with a pocket full of sand and the air guitar in my hand,
I replied,
I am a full time poets now roll up the dam to fight.
Okay.
I didn't actually say your roll up the damn divider but it would have been
awesome.
Or if I had right,
it would have been,
but you know what,
hey next time
and you better believe that will be no shortage of next times.
But that's the thing before you can believe it.
I got to believe it.
I got to believe there will be no shortage of next time.
That's why this thing that I'm doing tonight,
it's not just pretty words,
poetry,
poetry sake.
This is survival for me.
This is survival for us.
I mean this,
you know,
this is how we get through.
We have to have instant ways to access our power and our,
and our purpose and our passion,
our truth to,
to,
to get through those days and to do this thing.
We do this,
this entrepreneurial innovation,
you know me against the world instigation against all odds,
deaf to all the haters thing we did.
Okay.
Maybe not death to all the haters.
That's,
that's negative.
We'll stay positive like,
like,
you know,
stop feet and paper cuts and warrants to all the haters thing that we do.
Right?
And it ain't easy.
I know that,
I know that nobody knows them more than me.
It's why I'm a give you a powerful takeaway tonight.
Okay?
I don't care what it said,
the stage.
This will be the most powerful thing that you leave here with to help you get
through your challenging days of crafting your successful life and all you have
to do is repeat after me.
Right now at least I'm not trying
to build a successful life
from poetry.
I got no sympathy for y'all.
Please,
whatever.
Is it hard for you?
What do you have?
Tech Industry,
your billion dollar industry.
I built my business off the dead art form.
You hated in high school,
please.
Djs and state borders got it.
Easier than poets.
You know,
people,
look,
when I used to introduce myself as a fulltime poet,
people used to look at me like I said,
hi,
my name's [inaudible].
I'm a fulltime mermaid.
Nice to meet you.
All right?
They don't.
They don't get it,
but that's all right.
That's all right.
Because with every moment of confusion within someone else,
it was an opportunity for clarity of purpose within myself.
Right?
I had to believe that I,
and I did.
I believed that I could create a new user experience for the art form of spoken
word that could affect the masses.
I believe that I could dissolve the line between business speaker and
performance artists,
right?
And,
and,
and create a new experience that [inaudible] has to both.
And so against all the advice of everyone saying,
forget poetry.
Instead,
I embraced my ridiculousness and I created a new style of speaking called poetic
voice that just blends inspirational,
speaking with spoken word poetry to create an experience that allows me to go
out and inspire people and help them tell their story and it's sold them the
best version of themselves.
Right?
And to do that,
to awesome find my life,
I had to be okay.
I had to be fine with people not getting it the first time so that I could
believe in myself long enough to create no shortage of next times,
next times.
And now you don't have to guess just checking my specs.
I'm no longer afraid to double down cause I trick the deck.
I've already seen my future.
So I'm unfit to bet.
That's why whenever failure challenges me to Russian Roulette,
I rock a waterproof poker face impervious to sweat because I don't gamble with
my life.
I count the cards.
So my success is mathematics.
So long as my dealer with God,
I can always even my odd,
even on the Ids,
I can't get over it.
I go through it to this behind me on the days I can't levy the waves.
I just learned to surf tsunamis on the days I can slay the beast of despair with
my mighty sort of confidence.
Hell,
I can.
I can still took a razor blade beneath my tongue and paper,
cut despair,
one positive affirmation at a time.
And when I return home from the Wild Rumpus,
oh my awesome fest.
Oh,
always vacuum with a smile.
Okay.
As I clean up my awesome ness for their,
yeah,
there are bits of mountain top buried in the grooves of the soles of my shoes.
Every footprint tracked on my floor testifies to the height.
Soft climbed and proved I made it back home each time.
So please remember,
embrace your ridiculousness.
Okay?
Please go out there and vacuum with a smile.
Please remember you're awesome nation.
This and be the little extra cup for somebody else because I find that on those
days when my weary soul can't seem to do another single thing,
when the 24th hour threatens to pop my days scenes when the cup of my ambitions
begins to run it over into springs.
Perfect person at that perfect time says that perfect thing and I am handed an
awesome little extra copies.
Mama my homie shows up at my door with a bottle of Don Julio for dirty jokes in
a scrapbook full of,
we all laugh about this later.
A little extra cope by my lover sipping espresso at midnight in a fireproof suit
who takes over the juggling of MF Lehman storage and says,
you need to get some sleep tonight,
baby.
Yeah,
a little extra cup by my friends,
my family,
but my fans are my colleagues,
my community,
this kind of community that shows up at comes here to hear me inspired and
amazed and wants to hear that poem that ends with that fiery blaze,
but souls up to find me.
Having one of those days when I stand on this stage trying to guide someone
home.
It can't seem to believe the words of my own poem,
but you do.
Yeah.
You see in my story your truth,
you want perfection in process that you are wrapped Shah in route and us there
at my reflection in this audience,
his eyes and you stand back at your reflection.
My pupils provide and we shout aloud to ourselves with fire and pride.
I don't know what you think you see from your side.
Yeah,
but you,
you must not be looking at me.
That'd be cool.
Hi.
Wow,
awesome.
[inaudible]
this episode is brought to you by 99 when
your business needs a logo,
website,
business card,
thumbnail or any other design.
I recommend checking out 99 designs.
I use them myself.
I've used them for many years.
I used them to create book cover prototypes for the four hour body,
which went on to becoming number one New York Times bestseller.
I've also used them for banner ads,
illustrations and much more with 99 designs.
You get a variety of original designs from designers around the world,
give your feedback and then pick your favorite.
Your happiness is guaranteed to check out some of my competitions and designs
and some of your competitions and designs from fellow Tim Ferriss.
Show listeners@ninetyninedesigns.com forward slash Tim and right now you can get
a free $99 upgrade on your first design,
so check it out.
99 designs.com forward slash.
Tim this episode is brought to you by audible,
which I've used for years.
I love audiobooks and I've two to recommend right off the bat.
Number one is perhaps my favorite audio book of all time,
and that is the graveyard book by Neil Gaiman.
The only audiobook I've wanted to immediately listen to a second time.
As soon as I finished.
It's amazing.
You will thank me.
The graveyard book.
The second is vagabonding by Rolf Potts,
which had a huge impact on my life and formed the basis for a lot of what became
the four hour workweek.
So all you need to do to get your free 30 day trial is go to audible.com forward
slash Tim and you can choose one of those two books,
the graveyard book vagabonding or more than 180,000 audio programs.
So that could be a book.
That could be a magazine,
that could be a newspaper,
could be a class.
It's that easy.
Go to audible.com forward slash Tim that's audible.com forward slash Tim and
grab a book.
Enjoy.
You want more of the Tim Ferriss show,
you can subscribe to the podcast on iTunes or go to for our blog.com [inaudible]
dot com where you'll find an award winning blog,
tons of audio and video interview stories with people like Warren Buffett and
Mike Shinoda from Lincoln Park,
the books plus much,
much more.
Follow Tim on twitter@twitter.com slash t Ferris,
that's R R I s s or on Facebook at facebook.com/tim Ferriss.
Until next time,
thanks for listening.